but we begin this hour with reports of a
new version of the omicron strain also
known as ba2 or the stealth variant it's
reportedly been identified in dozens of
countries including the u.s scientists
say this sub-variant is harder to detect
some data suggests it could be more
contagious but there's a lot we don't
know cbs news medical contributor dr
david agus joins us to talk about that
and also answer your questions about a
range of other covet related concerns dr
david agus good morning how are you
doing
i'm doing good nate uh nice 67 sunny
here in los angeles
okay you don't have to rub it in okay
all right doc so what can you tell us
about this new omicron sub variant
you know it's called stealth but it's
really not stealth what it means is is
that uh omicron has two different
sisters if you will ba1 and ba2 ba1 is
the one that had been dominating the
united states and when you looked on pcr
it looked differently than delta did
b8.2 looks exactly the same as delta so
it's just as easy to detect it just
looks like delta on pcr and what we're
seeing is is that countries like denmark
which are weeks ahead of the united
states in dealing with omicron as a
whole you're seeing a significant rise
in b82 50 percent more infectious but
we're looking at with the booster you
have significant protection against bada
2 and that's what people really care
about doctor i guess we have some
questions from our viewers so we want to
throw some your way and hopefully we can
clear some things up for people that are
at home watching um our first viewer deb
she asks
the cdc now recommends n95 and k9 k and
95 masks but they're often hard to find
and expensive can you safely reuse these
types of masks
yeah early on in the pandemic the cdc
recommended against them because there
weren't enough for hospital
workers now there are
and so the thing about it is hospital
workers they have to throw them out
after every patient room because you
don't want to bring something from one
room to another but for the people in
the community when i go out i wear an
n95 mask and i wear it normally for
three or four days you know the
particles over time can get clogged the
the strap can get stretched out so you
don't want that to happen so three or
four days and then probably go to a new
n95 or kn-95 mask
okay good to know got a good question
now from syria zaria i hope i'm saying
your name right and your question is
this if you're still positive on a rapid
test ten days after the onset of your
symptoms are you still infectious
so what the data show is that about 50
of people by day five are no longer
infectious and about 90 percent by day
10. so if you're still positive it may
be what we call viral fragments so not
active virus that you're infective but
you may be in that 10 percent so i would
continue to wear a mask when you go out
and when you're interacting with anybody
if you were to continue to taste
positive at day 10.
dr agus sylvia would like to know how
best to protect children under five
given that they cannot yet be vaccinated
well sylvia asks obviously a critical
question in denmark now we talked about
that being kind of the lead place where
we're studying ba.2 the new variant 12
of hospitalizations in denmark 12
are under the age of two so we have to
protect that part of the population they
should have a vaccine we hope in march
as long as the fda accepts the two shot
data and is not pushing for the three
shot and then maybe a little bit longer
but when you go out you want to make
sure that that young child can wear a
mask wears a mask if they can and then
who they interact with is really
critical is that the people they're
interacting with they have to wear a
mask and so as much as possible protect
them there's hope around the corner we
will have that vaccine for that age
group and they will have protection
hopefully soon
a lot of people david are asking carol's
question and it's this how soon after
recovery from covid can you vaccinate or
boost
gail you know there's no real study on
this but my gut is three or four weeks
so three or four weeks after coven
infection if you haven't got a booster i
would go and get that booster shot or if
you haven't been vaccinated at all i
will s i would start the two-part series
all right i have a question from alicia
she has a question about what to do
after you have close exposure with
someone who has covet and she says she
asks we quarantine for five days pretty
much symptom-free and we are unable to
buy covet tests are we good to go after
five days good question
yeah it is a good question and so i i
would continue to wear a mat you don't
need to isolate but i would wear a mask
when you go out up till day 10 just to
be safe and i know it's really hard to
get tests out there and so everyone is
saying well do tests and you need two
negative tests in a row all of that is
true but we can't get the test we don't
have enough in this country and so use
caution and wear a mask with all
interactions up until day 10.
dr agus we have a viewer named cara who
asked a question that i think is on all
of our minds and that is the question of
the hour i would say is there an end in
sight say yes
[Laughter]
and the answer is yes i mean ba.2 this
new variant will slow the decline in
that curve but if you've been exposed to
ba.1 the first omicron if you will um
that you will have immunity hopefully
that will cross over to be a two and
since so many people have been exposed i
think we're going to see a decline and
really you know i had said before i
think it was mid february when we're
going to see that significant decline
it's probably going to be pushed out a
week or two because of ba.2 because of
this new variant that's now about nine
percent of cases in the united states
but we are going to be in a much better
situation come spring and so i think
toward the end of february and march
we'll have significantly lower numbers
of cases in this country and then
hopefully in march we could start to
vaccinate the under five and our
shoulders come down and so the key now
is that the people who aren't vaccinated
who have yet to receive a booster the
booster is critical for this new variant
that they get those and then we're going
to be in a much better situation in this
country
yeah we've heard this before i'm just
glad you can use the word decline
it's such a moving target but i like the
word decline in your sentence these days
thank you very much david agus always
good to see you